elon musk the richest man in the world
buying one of the most influential
social media platforms in the world
twitter
how will we change twitter how will he
change the way that we use social media
i want to talk about that with kara
swisher she's with us today she is a new
york times contributing writer the host
of the new york times podcast sway and
the new york magazines uh podcast pivot
and she's covered big tech in the
internet for many years cara really good
to have you with us i want to start with
asking you you said um when the news
broke that elon musk will make of
twitter what he wants
so what exactly does he want me how will
the look and feel of twitter change well
you know there haven't been many
specifics at all and he's talked about
things that have been planned by twitter
and haven't been implemented like
editable uh tweets where you can change
tweets and of course there's an edit
trace which has been around and had
facebook forever etc um and so they're
gonna do that they might he might not
allow
anonymity anymore possibly um that you
can trace the the account to a person
and that would lead to getting rid of
bots which would be a better experience
those are all product changes um he's
thinking of also changing the business
model away from advertising and more
towards subscriptions he's talked about
that broadly but not with any kind of
specifics
there's been a lot of suggestions that
you charge power users a monthly fee and
that there etc and then you remove
advertising from the the equation it now
makes up most of twitter's uh revenue
right now um he has to do something
around the business because it's pretty
bad it's not the it's not the strongest
business and given how much money he's
laying out he's got it and and getting
loans he's going to have to really turbo
charge its business and its user growth
so those are two important things um
around the free speech stuff i don't
know i don't know what his rules are
going to be
free speech for all is kind of vague
what does that mean what if it's this
what if it's that and i think he's going
to get sucked up into that just like
every other social media site has done
um and then there's rules around the
world which are different for every
country uh germany is very different
than the united states and there's
certain things you can't put up so he's
gotta adhere to those now twitter's had
the experience to do so but under musk
it might be a little looser would be my
guess
we'll come back to the free speech piece
but do you think that we could be paying
to use twitter in the coming months
i think there probably will be a paid
version that is a better version for
some people um it just makes sense in a
lot of ways they've tried it out with
twitter blue there's other ways to do
other things there's there's a thing
called mastodon which is using you know
being able to make you know disassociate
twitter from itself so people can make
their own twitters that's another scheme
that they have that jack dorsey it's not
a scheme it's just an idea so there's
all kinds of ideas but i would suspect
some sort of payment for twitter is
probably going to be in the works would
be my guess
you mentioned yourself it's not the best
financial deal perhaps for elon musk i
mean what is behind his decision to make
this uh purchase now
he wants it now that's why i don't know
what else to say he's the richest person
in the world and that's what he wants
now you know it's it is an opportunity a
lot of people have poked around twitter
and wanted to buy it either there's
controversial issues like whatever
donald trump was doing that particular
day there were the financial issues or
the fact that you know growth had slowed
a lot and it's never gotten as big as
other social networks uh like facebook
obviously but at the same time tick tock
and others have
zoomed past it and so it's not just a
question of size uh smaller entities
have gotten bigger whether it's snapchat
or uh instagram or which is part of
facebook or or whatever but they haven't
done enough to really turbo charge the
product and so he's got to do that
that's something that's really important
because he owes a lot of money in loans
and and a lot of stuff is leveraged
against his own tesla shares and if
something happens to those i mean say
apple announces a car thing whoa that's
going to be a problem for his stock and
so
um that could that could be a problem
for him
if we take a step back and look at the
bigger picture
we know that elon musk is beloved and
hated especially on twitter if we take
the perspective of people who believe
that he will be a blessing for twitter
open it up
um what good do you think he can do in
supporting dialogue and free speech
it's very difficult online i don't know
i don't know he might he he acts like he
has a magic bullet and i think a lot of
people have been working at this for
years um he's a very smart guy he runs
some very good companies uh not
everything is perfect at either of those
comp those there's more here's lots of
companies but the two flagship ones
spacex and tesla obviously is really
good at landing rockets on platforms in
the ocean but it's not the quite the
same thing to get people to talk uh
civilly that's a lot easier actually
from a from a technical point of view to
get that to do rockets is a lot easier
than because they
they tend to behave the way you
programmed them people do not
yeah twitter the past few years uh under
its previous leadership has been poking
focusing on healthy conversation trying
to promote better dialogue and also to
police some of the
misinformation disinformation on the
platform
is this going to be now the wild west
with elon musk at the head of it i don't
know i don't know i think he he doesn't
mind unhealthy dialogue i think i think
he doesn't think it's the worst thing he
thinks is better for democracy and you
saw his statement it was very lofty it's
a lot of words and it was a little bit
of a pr thing but i think he believes it
and it's hard
of course he would because he gets the
same thing he wants and he's from a very
safe place i think he's got to think
really hard about people who are less
safe than he is which is pretty much the
entire human race so i think that's
going to be an issue for him is to be
empathetic towards others who may get
kicked around on the platform of which
there are many
he also tweeted out yesterday that he
hopes that his biggest critics remain on
twitter because that is essentially free
speech but he doesn't respond very well
to criticism
what do you think he's going to use this
platform for going forward oh the same
stuff you know he really he's one of the
great things about it one he's got money
in the game right so that's a big deal
most of the twitter board did not have
that two he uses it he's a really he's a
he's a power user of the product and he
loves it he clearly loves it um you know
i think he's gonna be doing the same
thing some stupid tweets some obnoxious
tweets some funny tweets a lot of memes
a lot of weed jokes um and then
weird statements he just makes and puts
out there and then pictures of rocket
ships and uh and cars he likes to do
that so the same same old same old for
elon musk
let's play this out a little bit i mean
you've said that he would probably
reinstate donald trump uh because he was
against the decision to ban trump donald
trump from the platform originally
anyways let's say donald trump is
reinstated and on day one he says or
tweets out uh the 2020 election was
stolen
how do you imagine elon musk would react
to that i think he'd leave it there
i think he'd leave it
i do i don't know maybe they'd put
twitter was trying to put things on top
of that you know like warnings this is
actually what happened i don't know if
they would keep doing that under uh elon
it's still
i don't know i honestly i don't know if
donald trump's going to come back he
says he's not i don't believe him but
nobody you know you know usually when
donald trump says something you take the
under on on the opposite and you're
usually accurate and he can't resist he
can't resist twitter he loves it
another bigger
picture question rather um cara do you
think that elon musk could actually
reshape the way that we're
using social media on a whole
well anybody could do that at any time i
think tick tock's doing more for that
than anybody else you know you know i
maybe you know twitter has doesn't
hasn't you know bathed itself in glory
about size or impact and by the way it's
very popular on the media and
politicians and and other people like
that but most of the world isn't on
twitter and and that's the problem
that's the problem most people aren't in
this public square which is actually a
private square owned by a billionaire
but
that said it's a small little voice and
it has an outsized influence because of
the the people who use it and lose their
minds on it a lot of the time and enjoy
it other parts of the time
it's not the only big social media
company owned by a very wealthy man
is that a trend that you think we should
all be worried about well mark
zuckerberg got wealthy by creating a
social network elon musk got wealthy
making a car and and so you know and now
he's buying a social network yes rich
people have owned media forever i'm
sorry if you look around at ownership of
media it's always been the wealthiest
people in society um and so it's just
different wealthy people with different
attitudes and different power because
this stuff has much more power than uh
even tv networks or um newspapers in the
past you really can reach the entire
globe in a way you never could and so
there's quantum amounts of power here uh
quantum amounts of wealth and quantum
amounts of concentration of power and
that's always a problem in my mind
yeah i guess my point is that elon musk
and mark zuckerberg are all
representative of the people who are
using the platform well i guess the old
owners were the saudis so they're not
representative of many people i would
prefer to deal with so you know that's
what elon pointed out he pointed out
he's like oh well the saudis they're so
good and that's sort of a what about ism
but i'm with him on that one i have to
say
last question cara the eu in particular
has been moving towards cracking down on
social media companies on making them or
holding them responsible for the content
that they host
elon musk has made very clear how he
feels about regulation
particularly when it comes to his other
business interests what do you think he
will do how do you think he will deal
with
governments trying to crack down on
platforms like twitter going forward
well i think he's got some issues with
the sec he continues and will continue
to have he can only poke them so much
before they actually do something about
it especially if he does something
illegal or problematic or breaks a rule
this is very different europe has moved
really quickly around the digital
markets act all kinds of things that
margaret vestiger is doing
eventually the u.s will put in place
some sort of privacy bills or data bills
um maybe someday um you know when we've
all moved to mars with elon musk
but until then you know there's going to
be an increasing amount of regulation
especially around privacy and data not
around free speech that's sort of a
it's sort of a an a bright noisy bird
that everybody pays attention to on
twitter but really it's about privacy
and data in the end and that's where our
governments need to regulate and that's
what's worrisome is really
concentrated power with this enormous
amount of information about people